I feel like sometimes if I was the
picture relic as a person who'd be like
neo in the matrix and and like just the
bullets flying at them and he's like you
know that that cartoon with a dog in the
in the in the room and and and and he's
in the this thought bubbles everything's
fine and the room is like on fire in
some ways like with with what was going
on with THQ in retrospect we felt like
that dog because like we were trying to
do the right thing in the midst of like
just sleep yeah stuff we're trying to
have this game done in a couple months
and all of a sudden we may not have a
parent company you know there came a
point when all of a sudden there was the
bankruptcy and we're like oh that's the
end of the road
[Music]
doo-doo-doo-doo-doo-doo and second I
think collectively the franchises we've
done have have you know they've stood
the test of time they've they've had
great critical acclaim they've been
interesting and innovative and are
uniquely Relic I think all of them even
even as different as some of them are
they're uniquely Relic